it's a fool a Capcom exclusive in the
studio you taking me back right now man
like when you have records like that you
know it means something when you hear
those and you remember what you were
doing at that time
pull that do it when I wrote that this
is a family show right it's funny
because it's super 100 over absolutely
not during that time I remember being in
the studio with Jazze PHA
and he was just tripping because they'll
forget what city we were in but the
whole crew was together we was all in
the car and somebody was like yo what
area code is so-and-so somebody called
me from this area code and about three
people in the car automatically knew
because we was on the tour bus you know
I mean we picking up numbers from
outside with chicks everywhere so it
became a game and we all started knowing
what area code instantly was calling our
phone and that's basically where the
song the song came to be exactly
you got any for a tow 63 602 right I
live in Liu bang leave me right now
right now right now you know I might
have kept some as friends but for the
most part and I calm that down so I got
some questions um you know of course uh
you you gave ours remember man that
joint you they were Willy you gave
Phoenix the biggest shout out in that
joint
little noodle steps put out with Phoenix
AZ I got people on Twitter asking me you
know what's going on with Willie North
Pole of course you know he's still out
here we just spoke the Willie you got
some new records and everything he
showed ETP btp like in terms of him
having AIDS solidified distribution
through Def Jam no but we actually
having a conversation with him we trying
to get him through something else really
still working man what about the label
man I know you you had you know Shauna
yeah Chingy yeah yeah yeah you had a
play circle right sometimes man this is
the thing up at Def Jam there was a time
where they were playing so many musical
chairs with the executive order where
there that's real I mean like jay-z was
an executive yeah la Reed came in you
know what I mean Kevin Liles left you
had Leo a corn there was a time where
there was an understanding of all the
artists that we had through certain
people and then when new people come in
you have to try and get a whole new
understanding right so I didn't feel
like a lot of my artists were getting be
pushed necessarily I felt like they just
gonna do with you know I mean it it
didn't have anything to do with me it
had more to do with we're a subsidiary
so it's like disturbing the peace we got
to go to Def Jam and tell them this is
what it is this house you got to get
behind it so you know once there was so
much stuff going on and they didn't
really get the push that I feel like
they deserve at that particular point in
time we started trying to get people in
different positions in different places
where they can actually get that type of
push even if it meant them going other
places because I know that I know that a
lot of people like the internet talks
are like man Luda had to change this
whole time and now he changes this huge
star yeah man I mean clearly you're the
first to sign up so you saw that
potential in him I mean we did a deal
with Def Jam for for 2 Chainz so you
know I mean that it is what it is like
it's a beautiful thing he's with me so
long and we're still family and the
crazy thing is I love to see that that's
the whole point of being a CEO
you want to see anybody that you know
that was around you or that was a part
of your family do what he's doing right
now
so it warms my heart man that's honestly
what I want everybody to do I want
everybody to create they chapter in hip
hop the same way that I did honestly
that's real man that's real all right so
we got an exclusive about the play man
let's run men join it's actually leaked
this morning when I woke up I saw it
literally so it's gonna be this is more
like an exclusive this first time
everybody's gonna hear Bangladesh one of
my favorite producers man yes this joint
is bananas so we're gonna like play it
and then